ciao ragazzi ben tornati alla prima
puntata di mi rassegno stampa di marzo
ecco a voi adesso un riassunto dei fatti
salienti del mese perché l'ho subito con
la notizia che ha commosso tutti quanti
nuovi brad pitt fa voto di castità per
un anno dopo il divorzio dal genere ce
li avrebbe anche deciso di prendersi una
pausa dalle donne
questo vuol dire che gli uomini invece
vanno bene altro fatto veramente
importantissime che ha nevicato in tutta
italia a roma pure ecco qui alcune foto
ha nevicato a roma
selene un certo punto si è sciolta come
potete leggere buca capitale se
secreteria roma raggi scrivi ai municipi
se non siete mai venuti a roma non
fatelo in questo periodo dell'anno
perchè rischiereste di perdere la vostra
famiglia io stesso non trovo mia madre
da mesi anzi sedetevi se avete visto
questa donna si sta aprendo mentre mondo
no sono tutti i nemici che non ho
aggiunto nonno questi non li voglio
proprio nella mia vita ecco se avete
visto questa donna ha mandato un
commento qua sotto perché i figli la
stanno cercando
quest anno importantissimo evento è
stato quello degli oscar è stata la
novantesima edizione che avviene come
ogni anno questo interessante franco
nero trova finalmente una badante è
stato visto in compagnia di una ragazza
lei lui a 79 anni conquista una ventenne
state né chi è l'attrice emergente karen
caiazzo togli hai e ti sei già detto
tutto quanto arriviamo a quella che
secondo me è stata la mia notizia
preferita del mese che è quella della
grande polemica sulla pizza di cracco io
ho cercato di assaggiarlo sono andato
insieme a una mia vita qui presente al
ristorante abbiamo prenotato ci siamo
seduti e abbiamo scoperto in realtà di
aver prenotato il ristorante stellato
abbiamo preso un bicchiere d'acqua e
siamo scappati da allora solo spizzico
per me no un aperitivo sa bene tiriamo
fuori il menu i prezzi in realtà erano
dei dei codici alfanumerici lenny ball
abbiamo sempre di cracco pò ti fai è
riuscita a chiudere tutti quanti i user
cracco ati è scatenato un pochino una
bufera sui sui social
abbiamo per esempio alcuni commenti di
persone che dicono io per me la musica e
libertà non voglio comunque pagare
perché devo pagare per ascoltare della
musica non possiamo tutti volerci bene
da piccolo mio padre mi picchiava a è
già disponibile la nuova app che accada
per spotify andiamo avanti parliamo
sempre di aumento di prezzi
amazon prime aumentato il costo del suo
servizio qui dice da 19 euro all'anno a
36 euro l'anno c'è stata subito una
polemica per esempio amazon prime ora
costa 36 euro
lo dice dio e voi ancora vi lamentate
dell'otto per mille cioè tra l'altro che
è così indignato che propone di tornare
al baratto andiamo avanti tiziano ferro
tiziano ferro fa impazzire il web perché
perché posta una foto con un bambino
aspetta perché non ricarica che siano
ferro papa ma perché luni nominato io
sapevo solo che fossimo imbranato e sono
un imbranato
per fortuna oscurare la notizia di
tiziano è stato l'avvento del nuovo
messia stiamo parlando di leone gesù
lucia il figlio di chiara ferragni e di
fedex concepito senza peccato e
partorito della stessa grotta dove ha
partorito beyoncé
guardalo del casinò che regge il destino
meglio di me f un'altra notizia che mi
ha particolarmente commosso è quella di
stormy daniels quando sculacciato trauma
la pornostar infatti ammesso di avere
avuto un rapporto sessuale con il
presidente americano nel 2006 il fatto
che lei abbia parlato comunque mostra
che è una donna coraggiosa e soprattutto
con tanto fegato per specie qualificato
per trombarsi grande trump crampi mi
stavo uscendo un crampo allo stomaco
vuole inoltre questo mese stephen
hawking pochissimo in un letto i suoi
libri ma in molti abbiamo apprezzato nel
film alla teoria del tutto lo
ricorderemo anche per i danni ci parla
nel quale ha veramente un altro morto
del mese inoltre purtroppo e fabrizio
frizzi la voce dvd insieme al
rinoceronte bianco del nord che si è
estinto adinolfi ancora vive altri bivi
del mese sono pippo baudo la regina
elisabetta roberto saviano e al bano
questo mese poi non è successo niente
altro di interessante
ah no le elezioni chiudiamo infine con
la frase del mese che è chi va a letto
col culo che prude si sveglia col dito
che puzza
[Musica]